I sort of I mean I think of myself as a
theater man originally but actually the
first professional job I had was a TV an
episode of a TV show and I before I'd
left drama school I I got I was allowed
to go out to do a play and I came back
and then I was led to do a film so
before I even left drama school I'd done
a film I played on a TV show so you
might hit classmates hated me but I mean
I I feel like I think because I'm you
know if you are classically trained and
you have a sort of grounding in the
theater I think that kind of infuses
everything you do Brad it was kind of a
crazy experience because you know at the
time there were lots of these films were
made with you know the die cast are from
each country and it all being each
European country would put money in the
record Europe puddings for a while these
films so there's me from Britain
Sandrine Bonnaire from France and Bruno
ganz I think he had German money even
though he was Swiss and it was so
interesting because when Jane was a big
French movie star and I had to like go
to Paris and be photographed I mean your
photo shoot to see if I was like you
know a movie star it was really weird
and we shot it in Prague you're only a
couple of years after the Velvet
Revolution so I went since the wall came
down and so it was really crazy being
there because I remember like you had to
order if you wanted to go to a
restaurant you had to book it a week in
advance because we're still all in the
sort of a communist structure and you
would go and be totally empty restaurant
and I'm everyone - anybody got a salad
it was like a ball of sugary water with
some lettuce floating in it and one time
before the caterers I probably started
shooting when I was rehearsing I
remember something dinner with the
director and it was a slice of tomato
floating in my salad and I was like I
got it tomato and I thought I I need to
go home I used to go I need to cuz I
actually started eating meat again
during that film because it was so hard
to be a vegetarian
Romy and Michele's high school reunion
that film is really fascinating in that
you know it was the first film I'd ever
made in America the first time I'd ever
played an American I really still
continents time finally cast me actually
but I had never been to prom I never we
don't have high school reunions but I
come you know and none of those things
were common to me I didn't understand
what it was about I didn't know what it
meant to be to go to a prom or anything
I didn't even know how you pronounce
Tucson in the read-through someone said
to so and I giggled thinking they've got
it wrong thinking it was toxin nobody's
gonna say no to anyone tonight
[Music]
show
this is the last night of school at all
would you care to dance with me points
[Music]
as trying to like have this learning
curve at the same time is not let on
that I knew so little about American
culture but it's a great film in that
it's just become this thing that people
are obsessed with it you know like
people watch it every week and there's a
thing in my bar I have a bar code club
coming here in New York and on site and
Saturdays there's a Romy and Michele tea
dance and they play 90's music and and
they have different they have different
you know feature different sort of the
artist of the week but if when you want
to do a request for the DJ you do it on
a post-it and they have scarves for you
to fold on the bar it's hilarious so
it's got this you know incredible sort
of passionate following it really hit I
guess it hit a chord because most
Americans have proms and go to high
school reunions threw over for me it was
this you know it was like it was very
exotic and I really didn't know what I
was doing but and in the dance bit I
liked the dance bit because you know I
have danced to be bit so but again it
just felt like what the [ __ ] you know
we're doing this kind of rom-com and
suddenly there's a big dance sequence
[Music]
none of us had any idea be this huge
film you know 20 years later this
amazing black beauty I am the voice of
black beauty I am beauty if you will
once I discovered that he and I but the
two of us could become one this business
turned out to be perfectly glorious
it's quite funny so I was doing a film
in Ireland called circle of friends and
in a gap I went back and I was I did the
voice for this horse film and when I
went back to Ireland there was a black
horse with a white thing on his head
like black beauty in like when you came
out of this Abbey where I was staying
but on this field there was this horse
and it came to me a knight but I was
just it was magical and I also met my a
dear friend Caroline Thompson who wrote
and directed that film and I did another
couple things with her and that was the
first time I met her it's kind of crazy
when you say I am the voice of the horse
not not words you thought you would hear
yourself say but I really like it
actually and it's also what's hilarious
once I was flying to Mauritius I think I
was in those days where they had the
same film but like you can just flick
over and be different you know you'd be
dubbed so I could hear myself and I'd
flick over and it'll be someone
pretending to sound like me in French
and that I really loved that part I
actually met quite a few of the people
who dubbed me in different countries the
man who doesn't mean Brazil recently
contact me on Instagram they'd finish
the film and and I came onto it like in
post
so I didn't meet any of them I mean I I
knew a couple of them but no I'd know
it's kind of weird you know having that
like being such a large part of a film
that you've actually really very little
contacts a lot of but those sorts of
films animated films you actually it
only takes you like a couple of
afternoons and yet you know it's this
massive sort of thing
[Music]
well it's sort of one of these things
that you never I didn't grow up thinking
oh gosh I want to be in a Bond film but
when I was asked I was like what you
know it was crazy and it's also the
first there's been a gap he had done a
James Bond film for a long time so our
thing was being rebooted so it was even
more exciting
I was Pierce Brosnan's first one I know
so they had they had this thing where it
was like they weren't called Bond girls
they called them Bond women they tried
to kind of you know make it seem a
little less sexist than it actually is
and so I became her I was like a Bond
boy because I had shorts it was really
it was great fun I really had a great
time I mean I was paranoid I wouldn't be
able to do the pain thing took me ages I
remember remember like getting the
script and I'm thinking I'm trying to do
it and I couldn't do it and then I
showed my friend dicks yet said have a
redo the script it doesn't really my
could just something else couldn't I I
don't really need to do that and she
read it she went oh my god the whole
entire script of all around you being
able to do that thing with the pain
you've got to learn how to do it so my
friend Jason taught me and like it's one
of those things it's you know it's kind
of an iconic thing and also I think it's
the first Bond film I don't you know did
you again it was a Nintendo video game
and I remember when I found out there's
a while after the film came er I
realized that there was a Nintendo game
that I was in and as I had an assistant
at the time called land and I remember
saying Golan tonight and I'm in a video
game and he was like oh yeah I know I
haven't you know if you pissed me off I
go home and shoot you in the balls
so how lovely I am invincible
now people show I am invincible at me to
this day and I'm invincible
yes surely we were in a same stage in in
like Elstree or one of those buns and it
was remember a really hot day and we
were sort of been a thing and you know
that there were people fishing outside
good at this to make the cards correct
this and there was people throwing snow
like that outside the window so it was
ridiculous and there's a bit where you
know we keep going back and forward and
from one seat to the other and there's
one bit when I'm going to go in earth
goes over here like this and I said you
know I come up to a nice sort of whisper
in her ear and I go but the thing was
when I and to know whenever I see her
actually the eye I'll be chatting and
someone others come up and go allow me
to interpret this silence I go go ahead
that's become a sort of a line but when
I did the thing that lying to her
because nothing when you're not not
looking and someone comes up really
close to and whispers in your ear it's
really makes you sort of particularly
exposed makes you giggle so I did she
started giggling I started giggling we
could not get it together and Doug the
director said there was only really one
tick there's only one version of what
they had some of us not laughing
to complete the certain part of the
scene because we just couldn't get it
together
I need to interpret the silence I know
it was that I think was the last day of
the film we shot that on so we're all
just giggly and hysterical and you know
just people throwing snore all right the
wind you see their hands like in your
periphery you can see that mat like some
big some guy in its crew like when not
being attention it Vinnie put you off
spice round doing space what was the
most hilarious fun film because they
were the spices were like just it was
crazy going to work well be outdoors but
put me at base camp you know when you go
to the set where your Chile's are it all
had to be like behind these high fences
and because of all these twins would
like okay well when they opened the gate
I'd be like this whale of you know twins
screaming we all had these cars with
dark windows that they took us home man
and they would all be like screaming for
Jerry or something and you think it's
only me darling sorry to disappoint you
but it was it was a it was bonkers and
they were just I think they will it was
at their most sort of you know they were
still sort of innocent and loving it and
having this amazing time they hadn't got
sort of jaded and I just had a real
blast
[Music]
I really like that film it's sort of a
sort of real old-fashioned sort of caper
film and very you know parodies itself
almost and also I was taught all the
dance moves to the Spice Girls songs by
the Spice Girls themselves Eyes Wide
Shut there's so funny because that film
actually I made it right after no I made
it right before spice world even though
accumulators not funny so went from I
think I'm the only one ham I am the only
actor who's ever made back-to-back films
with Stanley Kubrick and the Spice Girls
but I loved that film it took forever it
was actually a nightmare in terms of the
lead up to it because you know they kept
me waiting there's months and they said
oh it's good it's going to be on Tuesday
no it's not it's going to be three weeks
on Wednesday
oh it's going to be in a month time and
it was just this one scene I had to
audition like six times and various
countries it's funny you should ask that
question in that bill because actually
there was something a little strange
about the way mr. Nightingale left yes
really
wouldn't what was that
he came in this morning about 4:30 a.m.
with two men Victor and eventually when
I did it I I did it you know I was
holding out to do it because I thought
this is stanley kubrick's probably last
Spellman what an honor but actually a
great time on it I really liked a loved
Stanley he was hilarious he wasn't
scared he like I thought he was going to
be I did stand up to him not something
quiet we got on I I met him and in early
in the morning with Tom Cruise and you
know we had come onto the set to
rehearse it was like 6:30 in the morning
I know hello I am I'm Alan and he went
you're not American Isaac I know I'm
Scottish
and you ain't you're American on the
tape and I was it yeah that's cuz I'm an
actor Stanley and he just sort of looked
at me and I could see that he was sort
of respected that I just kind of slapped
him the bits you know and after that we
got in really well and had a real laugh
actually and then and it was also good
because every time we did you know you
did thousands of takes and that one
little scene took a week to shoot but
every single time you went to do a tick
I understood why we were doing it again
it was little tiny little details and I
really it made me really appreciate
acting again and about how you know
there's no small parts just small actors
that sort of thing and it made me kind
of reinvigorated my interest in acting
actually because I worked sewed in a
such a detailed way on such a small
thing
The Spy Kids trilogy it's an amazing
thing having being mr. Floop because I
remember things I mean I remember
exactly the moment when young people
young adults changed their attitude
towards me in the way that they
approached me and it was because they
were kids who had you know seen spy kids
and now they were adults and they're
meeting me and it was before that it was
you know people like
you know a little bit cooler but yeah
yeah I like your work you know my
girlfriend likes you something and it
changed overnight too you are a part of
my childhood and this really magical
connection that I have with a whole
suite of young people and it continues
actually because that film people kids
still watch that film it has a sort of
aged out in a way and it is a really
lovely thing that I can I can tell by
the way people approach me if they're
coming to talk to me about spike it's
because it is like having you know like
a fairy tale character be in the bar
with you you know what I mean
someone has been a part of your charted
and I think that's very much
[Music]
[Music]
you can smile
you can dream
and like but when I you know when they
said Oh Robert Rodriguez is doing this
new film and I was exciting sums of
dashing film noir and then it was spike
is and I was at oh but I it's not what I
expected at all but I really liked it
and it was lovely going back as well to
to do the the sequels and of course none
of us had any idea that it was going to
be this huge thing I mean not at all it
was kind of amazing
and I really liked the film as well some
films I've been and I really like some I
don't a lot I don't spike as I like x2
[Music]
the makeup took about five hours four
and a half to pay you know the thing was
that all the tattoos they were added at
the very last minute so they didn't have
a chance to make up you know little
molds of them up whatever just bung them
on stick the one you had to be done by
hand every single day so there's these
two men with those kind of things like
you know they were squirts like you're a
sing a cake they're doing that on my
face for hours I mean it was just awful
but I really liked the film but you know
I think that's the thing often for me
what is important is the experience you
have that's more important than the end
product cause it's also you know so many
things can go wrong and actually I would
much rather have a great time than and
have a terrible film but at least it was
a good film a good way
it was a very new experience for me
doing the good wave because I've never
done at long-running television series
before I never really played a grown-up
before you know I was suddenly playing a
man in a suit and I was like I can't do
that I mean I missed a flip oh you know
I never most the people I played weren't
even human a lot of them so it was an I
feel like I grew up doing that show I
grew up as a as an actor and that I
could you know realize that you can you
can really build on a character and
actually it was a great thing sort of
lob things back to the writers and then
they would run with it and give it more
things to do you know because you know
you just in those long-running shows
you're making it up as you go along you
just suddenly can have an ex-wife or you
can suddenly have a child and I love
that about it it used to terrify me that
there was no end you know because if
you're used to always doing films and
plays you know when you need to script
what the ending is and where you're
going with the character a long-running
TV show there is no end so you have to
cut out give up a bit I just wanted to
say thank you that's all you didn't need
to my boyfriend's back from Las Vegas
I'm just saying that it's it's not a big
deal I'm just saying it I'm glad
I am no no you don't have to know what
you think really this is just a thank
you Natalie I know I know it's just nice
to talk that's all
and I realized you know I am a
middle-aged man in a suit and I can play
one and actually doesn't mean if
someone's ostensibly boring like you
know man in a suit that was a that was a
kind of a my prejudice but actually I
think Eli that character is one of the
most crazy people I've ever played it's
doing instincts really fun that gets
sort of it seems to me like a sort of an
old-fashioned show it's like an
old-fashioned cop show it's not gritty
reality like in the first episode of our
new season the first murder is a lady
who's frozen alive in her own cryogenic
chamber so it's quite sort of campy in a
way that are tone to it as a little sort
of heightened and I really like that and
my characters not he's sort of a
fuddy-duddy professor former spy kind of
you know all these things they only
happen on TV and it's the first time
they've ever had a a gay leading
character and in a network drama on
American TV so it's so it's nice a new
whole new thing and because of that I
think it's actually quite fun because
you're just you're there's no precedent
you know and I just wanted to I just
it's the first time I've been the lead
in a big big TV show and I just want to
have fun
you know I don't I realized that what's
really important to me is that everybody
are on to say it just has a good time
and you know we'll make it as good as we
can but it's also weird you know it's
not brain surgery let's just have a
laugh and be nice stuffing mines charity
akp
when you're directing and you're in it
you always have to look at yourself and
you don't do the usual thing of oh
you're very kind like okay that was fine
now I can cut that in that'll work
so you actually I like it because it
makes me less self-conscious about my
acting
but that film was nuts you know it's a
sort of kind of like a horror film
really and just created there's a
sequence with Karen black who is you
know sadly no longer with us but there's
a sequence where she comes to the house
that I'm living in with David Boreanaz
and she comes he brings her back
thinking that she's going to take him
away from all and and there's it's just
so dirty there's a new she's much much
older than David and she's drunk and
it's thunder lightning and everything
and she goes at one point because I want
you to [ __ ] me I want you to [ __ ] me but
first I want a tour towards which I just
thought was the greatest line ever
because I know what she means Josie and
the Pussycats
I like that film very another sort of
example of a film that that when it came
out they didn't know what to do with it
it was a weird film so it's like a
parody of itself you know and so they
end it at sort of twins and it didn't
really it didn't work it didn't really
go anywhere and it's one of these lumps
over the years people have come back to
it and it's got a sort of a cult
following and I really like I mean for
me what was so great was that I
basically killed a boy band within the
first few minutes of it which you know
was that's pretty good and I got to work
with parker posey and we'd actually just
we made two films back-to-back that was
the second one and that was really good
November when an actually rosario Dawson
who's in it I'm about to go and work
with her for the first time since like
20 years later working together again
yeah it was just really fun a really fun
kind of mad and I sort up ahead of its
time I think in the way that it parodied
a lot of product placement and marketing
and things
[Music]
I remember when Parker left this is like
20 years ago so I was only you know in
my early 30s and when Parker left she
wrapped dirty I was the oldest person in
the cast and you just don't expect that
to be the case when you're in your early
thirties not to be expected you like
maybe now but because everyone was so
young that any girls were like you know
ten Oh darlings Lord City yes you're our
guest
jiggly Caliente is the best I you know
love the show and I I used to see Alana
at my yoga class I remember one time
like I was behind her in this class and
she got up to go into and she we did it
kind of and later she tweeted at me but
over Suzanne I went yeah I'd the better
view though and and so then they just
asked me and I did it one afternoon and
it was it was hilarious and I just I
don't know they're such lovely girls I
mean just I mean so talented and clever
but just really nice both her mum's were
there and you know everything about it
is done with such kindness I really like
that well that's all we've got time for
I hope you enjoyed me blabbing on but
some of my films that I've been in if
you if I missed the one that you liked
then why do you not I'll be back in 20
years time to talk about some more
[Music]